the reach is aptly named
we're the ones who give your hands
something to do at the table as the most
fertile region of the seven kingdoms we
grow the lion's share of the grains and
fruit that feed this country especially
now since the rebels have burned down
the other fields thankfully house Tyrell
is here to do its duty to the crown and
keep the capital from starvation yet as
with all Gardens weeds grow in the reach
too though few named them as such
sinners fill our heads with chivalry and
courtly love fluff to make boys fight
and girls swoon oh the songs are good
enough for a pleasure barge down the
Mandor they give pleasure to the common
people and harmony to the realm but if
the rise of house Tyrell proves anything
it's that virtue and honor have their
place and if you're not careful that
place is the grave unlike the Lannisters
Starks and Aaron's we were never kings
in our own right house Gardner ruled the
reach since the dawn age and we were
their stewards while they Ward to enrich
their already rich domain we managed
their castle of Highgarden
but then Aegon Targaryen landed with his
dragons nobody knows why the gardener
King took the field against him anyone
could see that a man who grows flowers
should be where a man who grows
fire-breathing monsters but maybe it
wasn't wholly his idea maybe someone
whispered in his ear about all the face
he'd lose with the other six kings if he
stayed home the rest is history
the last gardener King lost his face
along with his body and his steward
Harlan Tyrell promptly yielded
Highgarden to Aegon my grandmother
swears that Harlan was like most of our
men and grew up banging steel together
too loudly for a thot to penetrate but
luckily his wife had better sense
whatever the case in return for Harlan's
show of sense Aegon proclaimed house
Tyrell the
lords of the reach and wardens of the
South passing over all the other houses
with better plains house Hightower who
were kings before the Andals came their
seat is the oldest city in Westeros they
call it old town wealthy proud and
solitary there have been high towers who
wouldn't come down from their great
lighthouse for decades its name
fittingly is the Hightower
house Florent who had actual blood ties
to the Gardiners they whinge about their
ancient rights to Highgarden every once
in a while and now that their daughter
is married to Stannis Baratheon about
their rights to all of Westeros -
apparently putting a fox on your banners
doesn't impart a Fox's wiles house Tarly
who still gives the reach for best
soldiers it has if Aegon had named them
as his lords the reach would have become
the greatest military camp in the world
until it starved to death the price for
conscripting all the farmers yet Aegon
chose us centuries later when his
descendant Aerys faced rebellion the
reach stayed loyal mostly my father mace
dealt Robert his only defeat in the war
even if it was my father's Vanguard who
did most of the fighting before he
arrived after the Battle of Ashford we
laid siege to storms end
Robert's home unfortunately the war
ended before we could take it and free
up our armies to go save the king the
new king Robert had a forgiving nature
our crimes were brushed aside without
even one execution for the sake of
formality our family was surprised
until Robert's new hand Jon Arryn came
by with the bill the reach is second
only to the westerland's in wealth and
Robert meant to spend as much of it as
he could get his hands on we gave him
the coins he wanted and later when he
wanted our grain or fruit or wine he
gave them back at whatever price we said
now much of
Duras is ashes the rest of it is armies
as the Starks are fond of saying winter
is coming and four leagues outside the
capital there isn't a harvest to be seen
have no fear the reach is as always
bountiful house Tyrell will manage the
harvest and keep the Seven Kingdoms from
starvation like the good stewards we
once were just asked house gardener